So, welcome everybody, Jason here. Jason Rosen here once again with Dr. Kevin Conners to
do another webinar about a product that we recently released, something I know that Dr.
Kevin you're really excited about, especially definitely lots of vitamin D3 products out there,
but when we and I discussed some of the unique features about this particular player, I know
you got quite excited and then adding the enzymes to the mix of it, you know, of course just
to help the absorption and that's the, you know, the D3's on. So, Dr. Conners, want you
maybe just comment a little bit about why you were so excited to bring this guy on?
Well, I'm always excited about D3 because of tree cancer patients and you want to prevent cancer,
you want to use D3, I mean, that's a key player in stimulated apoptonic receptors,
on cell membrane to stimulate apoptosis. So, it's an important factor. And the reason why I like this
product is it's a fermented product which always crosses the gut wall better. And again, like we talked
about every one of these webinars, anything you add enzymes to it just works better. So, it's a great
product, I think I really like about this product is the dosage. So, at 5,000 I use of D3, you know,
you have, I mean, typically if you're not dealing with the cancer patient, you'd have them just dose
at one a day. I have my cancer patients dose two or more a day measuring their D3, making sure that
we're not getting too high, but we also want to look at their genetics. If you're doing any genetics,
you look at their BDR receptor genes, their vitamin D receptor genes, to see how they do as well. So,
those are the things that you look at with BD, and make sure that you are, when you're measuring it,
you don't go off of the standards that the lab gives you, because I think the normal standards,
Jason from Kirchner, like 30 to 80, or something, are with a normal range. And I want my cancer patients
to be, you know, over 80 and, you know, up to 150. And if you have BDR gene defects, whether you have
cancer or not, you want to keep your vitamin D levels much higher than the normal range. So,
how about, you know, your traditional, maybe they don't have the gene defect, but an autoimmune patient
or someone struggling with a nail nasty, you know, infections? Well, you know, that vitamin D3 is,
is not a TH1 or a TH2 stimulator, it mainly stimulates the T helper cell system. So, it's, therefore,
an immune modulator. So, it helps balance a hyperimmune system if somebody with autoimmune issues
or allergy issues. So, that could be really beneficial with that. Also, just some critical pearls
with vitamin D3, if it helps anybody, people with any tech, cardiac issues, you can literally
be a lifesaver for somebody with a vitamin D3. So, deficiency in D3 is rampant,
and you can have a person with a vitamin D3 level measured at 60, and they're still showing level.
They're still showing clinical deficiency. So, I don't think anybody's too high in vitamin D,
unless we get over 200 out of blood tests, but it, and I've had patients over 200 out of blood tests
where they're like dosing, you know, if they come to me and they're dosing 20,000, I use a vitamin D.
I think you're getting too high at that point and they really decrease their dosage, but
otherwise, I want my cancer patients over 100 other blood tests. So, it's just, it's really important.
Yeah, and even for the docs out there that aren't, you know, working with, you know, these really sick
patients anywhere from autoimmune, all the way to nasty chronic disease, it's still something that
is just wonderful just to carry on yourself, even if you're just getting into nutrition, like we
talked about enzymes, and HCL is being a good place to really get started, and then I think
another great place to get started if you're a total newbie is, is right here.
Well, people are taking cholesterol or e-drugs, right? That's probably the number one prescribed drug
in America. A problem with that is that cholesterol in the bloodstream breaks down into the
byproduct, I think it's 125 hydroxy cholesterol, that is what makes vitamin D in the skin from the
sun rays. Right. So, the person has is forcing their cholesterol levels down with medication.
They're, they end up deficient in vitamin D. They can't make the vitamin D from the sun, because
people think, oh, I'm about in the sun all the time, I don't need any vitamin D. Well, measure their
levels, you'll still see that they're, they're very low in vitamin D. Do you think, well, why is that?
Do we bet to have to take a vitamin capsule all the time? Well, though, it's because the interaction
of the medications people are taking, affecting the liver, affected cholesterol production, affecting
the ability to make vitamin D in the skin with sunlight. So, it's, it's kind of a negative cycle. So,
if you're just even doing chiropractic, and you even have any idea what people's cholesterol levels
are, or you know that they're on a lipitor or something like that, it's good to get them on vitamin D.
In this beauty of this product, you could just have to take one a day, go to say, it lasts them for
four months. Right. And it's, it's a, it's a pretty cheap product. Yeah, it's definitely a very
cost-friendly product. And what, you know, we've done here is try to make something like we always do
that's unique. So, we're going to get a lot more into this form of vitamin D3. And then of course,
the enzyme blend, which you know, most people know anyway to get anything in out of the cell
requires an enzyme. So, that's another thing we want to add to this just to give it that extra boost
because there's a lot of issues out there with, you know, traditional D3s and cell absorption. So,
we've conquered it from two levels, the enzyme, and then this form of D3, which we'll get into next.
So, Dr. C. Wanchitels, a little bit more about this, this fermented D3 that is also vegan,
which is another, you know, really nice, I guess, selling point about this product is most D3s come
from animals from sheep's wool. So, you know, once you take it away here for us.
Well, that does begin a lot of your patients that are concerned with their products.
So, number one, if you have a person that wants a vegan product, here's your product for D3.
But I think it also has to do with how it's going to be utilized by the body. So, anything it's more
natural whole food form, it's going to be utilized better by the body. So, for a fermentation
process of any nutrient that was a great selling point for some other products that used to be involved
with Jason, your body can utilize it better. And it has to do with your microbiota.
So, if your microbiota is going to be able to recognize it and bring it across your cell membranes,
it's with your epithelial cells and your gut wall, you're going to be able to absorb it better.
So, it has a lot of great selling points to it. So, even if you left out the enzymes,
it's still going to be a better product as far as absorption of D3. But then you add the enzymes
and it's a double win. Yeah, completely agree. It just solves a lot of questions that people have
with D3 even like an emulsified version that says in our minds anyway, it's going to be even more
severely absorbed. So, yeah, definitely if you're used to giving your people high amounts of D3,
you know, burn the blood lab maybe a little bit sooner than you're used to just to, you know,
see how quickly you're getting that patient into range and then keep them on that maintenance dose.
I always tell my patients to put their D by their toothbrush. So, they remember to take it every day.
So, it helps, but it helps my patients. It's just a must that they have to be taken every day.
Yeah, I agree. The old medicine cabinet trick is great for enzymes as well. So, keep it right there
with your enzymes and your D3. It makes it a lot easier to remember to take it every day.
So, anything else before we close out here that you'd like to mention on this product?
I covered everything.
Yeah. Well, we hope this is going to be a big blessing for a lot of people's practices and answer
a lot of questions or objections you might have with some vitamin D3 that you might be currently
using. And as always, if you want to learn more about the products, you can visit our website,
email me, and then here are the links to both of our YouTube channels where this and other videos
that doctors, counters, and I have done and we'll be doing. So, thank you so much, everybody,
and you know, have a great night. All right. Bye-bye.